Okay just a couple of helpful tips, to reiterate the one
I just gave you before is, always automatically escape variables when
possible. Not every template language will allow you to do so,
but always give it a look. Jinja certainly allows you do to
so. So in this class you should definitely do that. Next
is, minimize the code that you include in templates. What I've showed
you so far is statements and foreloops. That's about it. Jinja
will allow you to put almost, like arbitrary Python into your templates.
But, you remember the whole reason we're using templates
in the first place is, so we don't have to
have HTML in our code, likewise we don't have code
in our HTML. Because it makes it very difficult to,
to modify, to edit, to debug, all those things.
It's a total pain. So, and of course, the inverse
of this is minimize your HTML in code. I generally,
I have a rule generally, where we have zero HTML
in our code. Even if it's a little one-line thing,
we put it in a template. That way all your HTML
is in one place, all your code is in one place,
and you don't, your not using the wrong tool for the
job. Which inevitably will bite you down the road as
your projects get more complex. Those are just some things you
know, these aren't hard and fast rules but these are things
that I've found that have served me well over the years.